tentative d'évasion la nuit dernière la
prison parisienne de la santé trois
hommes dont 10 georges le tueur présumé
de plusieurs femmes en 97 98 en région
parisienne trois hommes étaient pourtant
dans des cellules du quartier
d'isolement récit audrey goutard avec
dominique bonnet pour s'évader de cette
prison des lames un drap noué et des
barreaux de chaise
la belle avait été minutieusement et
très discrètement préparé mais guy
georges et ses deux complices sont
tombés sur une ronde de nuit les
gardiens ont eu chaud en effet d'autres
détenus ont réussi à s'évader de la
santé avec ce même scénario
vous avez un détenu du yen ya quelques
années qui qui avait scié les barreaux
de sa cellule et qui avait fait habiter
les ferries qui s'était évadé on n'a
jamais retrouvé d'ailleurs vous aviez ya
quelques années aussi un autre détenu
dans le même style de déviation avait
aussi intercepté au moment où il extrait
de sa cellule
guy georges le tueur présumé de l'est
parisien doit être jugé en mars pour des
viols et les meurtres de cette jeune
femme
un procès cannes gauthier la mère de
l'une des victimes
adam depuis maintenant trois ans
l'annnonce de la tentative d'évasion a
été pour elle un choc terrible en qu'il
puisse s'évader avec deux autres
codétenus
non pas parce qu'un maton aurait oublié
de fermer la porte mais en limant les
barreaux de sa cellule on est dans un
film de américains là en plein en plaine
en plein délit pour l'avocate de guy
georges cette tentative d'évasion est un
acte de désespoir
il est seul en cellule il est seule en
promenade
il le vit bien sûr mal est peut être
encore plus mal parce qu'effectivement
et il les séparer et isolé des autres
détenus
une enquête a été ouverte pour
comprendre ce qui a pu se passer
comment ces détenus se sont procurés les
lames comment ont-ils pu communiquer
alors qu'il se trouvait à l' isolement
bon